il ya des villes qu'on identifie à coup
sûr un coup d'oeil rapide sur un
bâtiment au style architectural bien
prononcé et on peut facilement dire
paris londres bruxelles prague
alors c'est vrai pour certaines villes
mais évidemment pas pour toutes car les
images que je viens de vous montrer
elles proviennent d'une seule et même
ville à savoir lille lille où je me suis
rendu il ya quelques temps pour réaliser
cette vidéo sur son architecture ne sais
pas s'il architecture ça vous parle
peut-être pas mais étudié l'architecturé
c'est en réalité un excellent moyen de
comprendre l'histoire d'une ville ces
rapports sociaux et ses influences
artistiques
la première impression que j'ai eue de
la ville en arrivant pourrait se résumer
ainsi
c'est quoi ce bordel de la brique de la
pierre du néoclassique du flamand de l'
architecture moderne contemporaine de
l'art déco bref un bon gros mélange de
styles que j'ai essayé de détricoter
il n'échappera à personne que lille est
une ville frontière ce qu'il expose
davantage aux influences des pays
voisins en l'occurrence l'angleterre la
belgique les pays bas du fait de sa
position géographique lille a également
une fonction militaire importante ses
frontières sur constamment menacé sa
forteresse et sa citadelle construite
par vauban dans la seconde moitié du
xviie siècle
en témoigne lille a la réputation d'une
ville industrielle notamment à la
production et commerce de textile depuis
la fin du moyen âge mais c'est
réellement au 19ème que l'industrie
textile et métallurgique va connaître un
essor économique considérable qui va se
refléter nettement dans l' architecture
des habitations et des bâtiments publics
on pourrait croire que ville
industrielle signifie ville ouvrière
certes pour des raisons évidentes de
main d'oeuvre mais ville industrielle ça
veut avant tout dire ville d'industriels
patron ingénieurs grand bourgeois
lille est un lieu où cohabitent des
grands patrons et les ouvriers
d'un côté une classe dirigeante est aisé
de l'autre une classe populaire et
défavorisées on pourrait s'arrêter là en
ayant dit l'essentiel
mais reprenons depuis le début lors de
la première révolution industrielle
il y as pénurie de logements ouvriers
les habitations sont donc élevées à la
hâte avec de mauvais matériaux empêchant
la construction sur plusieurs étages
c'est d'ailleurs l'une des premières
choses qui me frappait dans cette ville
une ville sans auteur avec deux ou trois
étages maximum la cour et devient
l'habitat industrielles typiques de
lille et de son agglomération
elle est composée d'une ou deux rangées
de maisons au coeur d'un îlot
d'habitations cernant une courbe cette
extension anarchique et très rapide des
petits quartiers favorisera chez les
familles ouvrières l'insalubrité et la
pauvreté
progressivement la bourgeoisie va
redessiner la ville grâce à la fortune
acquise par les activités textiles
la priorité c'est d'agrandir c'est à
dire au delà des remparts hérité de
vauban et d'assainir la ville en
régularisant les canaux pour limiter les
inondations les grands projets
d'aménagement du paysage urbain
commenceront dès 1851
on construit des places des ronds-points
des portes triomphale banquiers
industriels propriétaire ou simple
rentiers achètent des parcelles le long
de ses nouveaux axes pour y bâtir des
hôtels particuliers et des maisons lille
est alors une ville façonné par la
bourgeoisie et le restera car le but est
de spécialiser les quartiers et non
d'améliorer le logement ouvrier
ces réaménagements prennent pour modèle
des villes comme londres et paris on
suit les grands chantiers parisien
initié par le baron haussmann les
boulevards deviennent des espaces de la
bourgeoisie lilloise la mode est à
l'éclectisme ce qu'on voit bien dans les
différents styles de façades de la ville
lui néoclassique à l'art nouveau d'abord
puis à l'art déco jusque dans les années
30 la brique lapierre parfois l'alliance
des deux c'est un peu l'image que l'on
se fait des villes du nord de la france
et de l'europe
pourtant en me documentant et c'est à
dire que c'est un autre matériau qui est
à l'honneur à lille bien que dissimuler
j'ai nommé le béton armé malgré les
bombardements de la première guerre
mondiale
lille a conservé son centre historique
intacte la place rihour la grand place
et celle du théâtre on échapper aux
bombes pour les bâtiments et rues
touchées la politique adoptée a été la
suivante reconstruire à l'identique mais
en intégrant de nouveaux matériaux plus
résistants est un combustible et pour
cela le matériau parfait c'est le béton
armé
en réalité on a du mal à croire que
derrière ces façades classique de
pierres ou de briques se cache une
structure en béton armé
côté déco on respecte scrupuleusement
les styles historiques anciens et
régionaux quitte parfois à en faire des
caisses cette campagne architectural de
l'illusion est une décence face au
nouveau parti pris moderne imposé par
des architectes de renom le corbusier
mallet stevens qui prône architecture
fonctionnelle les lignes épurées l'avant
garde et le régionalisme vont
s'installer dans la ville et venir
accentuer toujours plus les contrastes
visuels
un exemple de l'architecturé
régionaliste c'est typiquement la
nouvelle bourse louis marie cordonnier
s'inspire pour ce bâtiment du maniérisme
flamand mais utilise de nouvelles
techniques comme celle du béton armé
anecdote au passage durant sa
restauration de 1987 à 1997
on a tenu à garder toutes les pierres
d'origine même celles qui n'étaient plus
saine pour préserver au maximum son
style et la polychromie d'origine on
peut aussi évoquer l'hôtel de ville
connue pour son beffroi de 110 mètres de
haut qui est à l'époque la tour de béton
armé la plus haute du monde
c'est véritablement un triomphe
technique est une vitrine pour les
entreprises qui ont oeuvré à sa
réalisation
pour l'avant garde et l' architecture
moderne ce sont essentiellement des
étudiants issus des classes aisées qui
vont s'y intéresser
en particulier lorsque l'architecte
mallet-stevens prend la direction de
l'école des beaux-arts en 1925
robert mallet stevens se fait connaître
dans les années 30 par la construction
de la villa cavrois du nom du
propriétaire un riche industriel qui
construit à croix cette villa est une
oeuvre d'art totale que je vous
conseille d'aller visiter
l'élément le plus frappant c'est qu'elle
a pour unité de base la brique
vous vous souvenez de votre construction
lego et ben là c'est le même principe a
aucun endroit la brique n'est coupée
pour s'adapter aux dimensions ont la
garde
impact et on la met en valeur la brique
est un outil de langage signe de
richesse et de réussite pour certains ou
signe de pauvreté pour d'autres elle est
dans les vieux quartiers de lille le
plus souvent cachés sous des couches de
peinture et de crépy pour donner
l'illusion d'un parement plus classique
et aussi pour briser la monotonie des
habitations
à quoi ressemble lille aujourd'hui
prenons un peu de hauteur pour dire
qu'il ya comme des villes dans la ville
plusieurs mondes qui se côtoient un
nouveau quartier d'affaires qui se veut
le signe d'une métropole européenne
active et créative et puis les vestiges
d'une ville d industrialiser précarisés
et bien moins visible
le contraste dont je vous parle depuis
le début de la vidéo est bien là encore
aujourd'hui il m'a sauté aux yeux
lorsque j'ai tourné ces images et je
pense qu'il en serait autant pour
n'importe quel voyageur arrivant à lille
vous sortez de la gare et le récent
complexe euralille se dresse au dessus
de vous et ses grandes tours de verre
construite par des grands architectes
surplombe la ville deux mots au sujet du
projet euralille c'est un ensemble
isolé qui n'a jamais été intégré à la
ville c'était d'ailleurs la volonté de
son concepteur
ce onzième quartiers lillois est par
essence une anti lille qui a ses codes
propres ceux des nouveaux quartiers
d'affaires qu'on retrouve dans la
plupart des grandes villes européennes
on peut remarquer que comme toutes les
autres métropoles françaises
la ville de l'île est confrontée à un
processus de gentrification la
gentrification c'est l'embourgeoisement
de la ville
l'appropriation par des couches aisées
de quartiers populaires des quartiers
comme le vieux il
autrefois insalubre est devenu
aujourd'hui le plus cher de toute la
ville autres quartiers concernés celui
de wazemmes au sud ouest de la ville où
l'habitat ancien a été réhabilité dans
les années 80 et est aujourd'hui divisée
de part et d'autre d'un marché
cosmopolite des étudiants et artistes
d'un côté les classes populaires de
l'autre la préservation de la richesse
architecturale de l'île de ses diverses
influences à travers les âges en a fait
une ville très agréable à vivre ville
aérée contrastée mais le défi actuel et
sans doute au delà de la mise en valeur
de ce patrimoine de conserver la mixité
sociale qui lui a permis d'exister
[Musique]